so let's think about how these different
projects allow us now to study the
microbiome to understand first of all
healthy microbiome and healthy variation
right so we'll look at this left side of
the screen the human microbiome project
you can see some examples here american
gut project british cut project
etc
okay let me take a look at
some of the questions
okay so um are there any specific
databases related to cancer microbiome
and cancer so there are some studies
that have shown
a specific variation in the microbiome
that can lead to more successful
treatments for example with
immunotherapy
right we'll talk about this in a little
bit but um essentially
one thing that we need to understand is
that we need to have a healthy baseline
right when you think of any pathology
any condition you're comparing it to
someone and we'll see first of all the
variability in the healthy microbiome
and after we take a look at the at the
healthy microbiome we'll also discuss
how this applies to medical applications
and to our understanding of what i'm
saying um i've got a question why does
every time
uh elia i'm so sorry to intro but we
can't hear you i think you're on mute
sorry about that yeah
thank you so
um uh so yeah so what i was saying is
that there is this in utero colonization
hypothesis this hypothesis is um that
there is a
a microbiome that is passed to the baby
in the uh
uterus
um
and
so uh solidica i think there's somebody
uh here that is um not supposed to be
here
um okay so um
this hypothesis uh claims that um
there is a way uh to
pass the microbiome to the baby from the
mother and the womb
there isn't maybe enough um
evidence that that is uh conclusive
and um as a result we won't focus on
that hypothesis but let's talk about
some of the additional factors that do
play a role in the development of the
microbiome that have been studied
extensively in infants
infants that are between zero and three
years
so um
so malika would you be able to just
remove the people um that are
yes i'm doing that all right so some of
those include gestational age so how
long uh baby stays in the womb
uh the birth mode uh for example
caesarean or natural
sanitation
antibiotic exposure is a major one
um as well as host genetics
so several different studies have
focused on trying to understand these
factors in detail
and now we have some evidence of how the
composition changes and how
specific presence or absence of bacteria
could be linked to some of these factors
now what happens in the early ages is
that because this is an anaerobic
condition
specific types
of
bacteria start developing
and what you can do as i mentioned the
link
that i
just shared with you to the silva
database will allow you to
search for some of these bacteria so for
example we can take a look at
clostridia
and search for this name
in that
database so
let's take a look at that
so you would go right here
and just type in clostridia
and press on search
okay so as you can see
um clostridia again you can go kind of
from the higher level of toxitonomy all
the way down to the more detailed one
so this is a fermi acute
right
basili
um
eraser er easy pillar trick haleys
right i'm not going to try and pronounce
this but you can see the variation right
here
at this level of how many different ones
you're going to be able to find and so
you can zoom in
okay you can zoom in and you can see
that there's a lot of
variability
so again
there's going to be
a lot of
a lot of variability and that is
essentially what makes it so difficult
to study this kind of variation
at the lower levels right so the lower
the level the more detail we get
but at the same time we're going to be
getting uh
we're going to be getting
um you know a lot of information
potentially from that so
here is an example
of a study
that
was done on the effect of
probiotics
on the infant development specifically
infants
that are
pre-term infants pre-term birth so here
you can see composition of the gut
microbiome at the early phase of
development dominated by four phyla
active bacteria bacteria aditis
firmicutes and proteobacteria right so
we just saw that these are specific
types of bacteria right and here we can
see
that it is dominated by these specific
groups of bacteria
the adult microbiome so again
this develops over three
first years typically
so there's less of a
diversity at the very very early
stage and then that diversity grows and
starts to become established during the
adolescence so from
that early
childhood all the way to the end of the
adolescent period the microbiome becomes
established and the primary factors that
affect the established microbiome are
the use of antibiotics so how frequently
and how intensively those antibiotics
have been used as well as the level of
exercise and of course diet
and so here you can see the adult
microbiome and this is well
characterized in the human microbiome
project
is really divided into these several
different categories by the major
factors that continue to affect the
microbiome over the course of the adult
stable condition and those are specific
enterotypes two or three enterotypes
that are well studied uh body mass index
exercise frequency different types of
lifestyles and then a major component
are cultural and dietary habits
so here we can see
a major thing that you want to think
about as you kind of look at this
healthy microbiome is uh diversity and
balance um as well as this dysbiosis so
how it changes how it becomes
you know dominated by a particular type
of bacteria that is maybe able to
colonize and suppress other types of
bacteria reducing the diversity and as a
result the function also changes and so
we'll see how that
kind of looks like in the data itself
so
first of all let's briefly talk about
these as anterotypes so different types
of publications have been
focused on understanding these
enterotypes but basically um we can look
at two or three different enterotypes
so here's an example in specific types
of bacteria bacteriodes uh prevotella
and
rooming caucus for example you can see
that they change in terms of their
relative abundance
but basically
specifically those that are interested
in the diet
you know they've been able to categorize
these three different enterotypes into
those that consume carbohydrates like
fruits and vegetables
then what we call the western diet
so bacterials dominant types
and those are the western diet because
they're associated with kind of uh you
know the typical western diet like meats
uh potatoes and you know things like
that
and then there is an additional cluster
that is not as dominant but it's
primarily for those that are coming from
rural agricultural communities they
don't have a lot of variety in their
source of nutrition
and
those are typically
farming communities
so
those are the kind of major emerging
trends right that have uh come out of
these studies um they've shown that
there's definitely an association of
microbial diversity because of the
type of a
civilization so to stay or
community that the samples come from so
especially talking about the human gut
microbiome
it could be categorized as very high in
this remote hunter gatherer population
kind of reduced but still pretty high
microbial diversity in the traditional
farming or fishing populations and then
lower diversity
in this western european and
industrialized populations and so here
you can see
also how
some of these variations have been
associated with geography
so one major reason is because the same
trend of industrialization could be
tracked across geography
but also
not surprisingly some of those habits
associated with the type of food could
be found within a specific population
that maintains a specific aspect of
lifestyle and
food consumption so a good
review right here
geography ethnicity or substance
specific variation in human microbiome
composition and diversity
you can see
sorry let me go back
and share the link from this publication
i found it um interesting if anybody's
trying to understand more
how this
healthy human microbiome
varies and and what kinds of factors
are there
okay now because of this variation so
again think of the microbiome as a
community once that community is stable
it assumes certain functions that are
linked to immune
responses to different infections
they form a film a lot of times that
film is protective uh and so because of
that they're able to
kind of help protect
us from a variety of different
infections also by uh maintaining a
certain uh immune response readiness for
a variety of uh intruders that come but
because we also spoke not just about the
bacterial communities but we also spoke
about the viral communities
these microbes
are obviously involved in a variety of
different diseases and so the
understanding of not only the bacterial
diversity that we just spoke about but
also the potential of these viruses to
be present and develop and
get into the organs are very important
and here are some examples
of viruses that cause human disease so
also something that we can look at
as we study the microbiome
epstein-barr virus
the herpes family viruses in general
human papillomavirus and hepatitis b and
c are major conditions that drive about
a quarter of cancers right so the link
between microorganisms and human health
and disease is very
direct and so we can see
one perspective when we look at the
microbial diversity and community that
is in a uh
in this whole beyond
relationship with the host
so it it continues to co-exist in a
beneficial uh
way with the host um and then we can see
uh some of these uh becoming uh
dangerous and causing
disease
okay